the gyro can experience there's got to
be more emphasis on testing and there's
got to be more emphasis on showing
people how to keep their immune system
healthy and then recognizing people that
can't do that and doing what we can to
protect them I was [ __ ] with Bill
burr to try to get him to have rant
people think I'm really serious about
that it was like what are you gonna wear
a mask and I see bill over there steam
and I'm like here he goes here he goes
look I wear a mask whenever I go out in
public because it's the law and I don't
want anybody yelling at me but also
though when you know I guess excuse me I
get tested all the time to what's on a
side note what how great is burr he's
the best I love him she's funny he's so
funny and so prolific but here's the
thing
that I almost love even more it'll just
send me like a video of like a great
drummer that he loves oh yeah yeah I
took it up but he's really good but I
just love that dude he's so good he's
great and I love getting them wound up
that's what I was doing with the whole
mask thing apparently I was like really
arguing you shouldn't wear a mask or
you're a [ __ ] god it's but that's also
the problem with sound bites on Twitter
yeah it's you know it exists it's the
content Factory and you know anybody
that creates content you know then that
goes out into the world and look they're
looking for eyeballs too and that's why
I always feel like like I take [ __ ] but
I can't complain about it because that's
part of the game right that's part of
the game that's what I do for a living
so like when people say let it go
correctness it's overwhelming I just say
like amen it's just other people pushing
back and getting to say their [ __ ] and
that's exactly what they should be doing
the internet and it's democratized you
know outraged and there's more speech
now than there's ever been before in the
history of the world like we all know
you know it's like that what's the movie
with Mel Gibson where he knows what
women what would you think yeah right
so yeah ESP Twitter and the Internet is
just
we all have developed ESP and now we
know what everybody is thinking it's all
every day we're just bombarded by what
everybody's saying well you're also
bombarded by the people that spend the
most time doing it because there's a lot
of mentally unwell people that spend
their entire day camp down on Twitter
having arguments and if you want to
venture into that world and risk your
consciousness and your health your met
your literal mental health by
communicating in this really crude
manner with text messages and you know
arguing over semantics with people that
you don't even know it's it's a terrible
way to exist are you on Twitter do I
have a Twitter account but I don't read
it it goes 'i know i post things on
inner on instagram they go to twitter
occasionally i post things on twitter
but i don't read it it's just too toxic
man i get it you know and i know when i
[ __ ] up and I know when people are mad
at me when it's legit and valid and I
know when they're mad at me for nonsense
and I I'm my worst self critic so I
don't need other people yelling at me I
know what I did wrong I stay clear
healthy I think that's the only approach
you can have in this environment I think
it's a healthy way to look at it and you
know I always try and keep myself like
you figure when when people are coming
at you there's probably gonna be
something constructive in there
sometimes I put energy to like find it
and sometimes I'm just like I really can
you just yeah sometimes you can't do it
but yeah there's value in criticism it's
very important but not too much it's
like anything else like you there's
value in a little bit of snake venom you
develop a tolerance but if you get a big
fat dose you're dead and it's in in many
ways is the same with interacting with
people that are upset with you there's
gonna people people that are upset with
everybody for no reason no matter what
the story is in the news even if it's
clear-cut to you and I there's gonna be
someone who has a violent opposition to
that idea it doesn't mean they're right
it doesn't mean you're right it just
means people have a lot of different
[ __ ] ways of looking at the world and
if you want to exist in conflict in
perpetuity stay on Twitter and stay on
Twitter all day long and just argue with
people I don't want to do that you know
and again it's not that I don't have any
room for improvement it's not that I
don't appreciate or accept or recognize
the value of criticism because I
definitely do it's that it's
not healthy it's not healthy for me it's
not it could directly affect the kind of
content I put out it's not good that's
what I was upset do you feel like one of
the hardest thing to do is to maintain
your kind of creative barometer so that
you don't let those kinds of things when
you feel like they're not constructive
fully too far to the outrage world or
some other things like to maintain that
and that's why I think it's good like
what you do in terms of Congress is like
you basically say you know I'm gonna do
long form because that you know feels
like at least from my perspective the
healthiest form yeah it's conversation
but is even in that case people will
take long form edit things out of
context and then it becomes the same
problem that we have Twitter and with
everything else you get these little
sound bites so there's little video
clips and you don't understand the full
context of the conversation or what was
actually said and then people get
outraged at that it's you know it's we
are living in a very strange time and I
believe it's an adolescent stage of
communication and I think it's going to
give our frustrations for this are going
to give birth to a better form and I
think one of the things that podcasts
what it's in response to the popularity
of the long-form is in response to
people being upset with like these
traditional late-night talk show things
where there's a window here with one guy
on the right and a window here with a
guy on the left and as a person in the
center and they're yelling at each other
and then you cut to commercial and you
don't really feel like things got
resolved so the response to that where
people gravitate it's three is theater
yeah
[Applause]